And I was just supposed to say, death, death, death.
And I think they turned the microphone all the way down.
But still, I was standing there in front of that audience with Metallica just realizing,
wow, this is the best idol that I've ever met.
All right.
So I wanted to start off this episode a little bit by saying, you know,
NTY, I'm super hyped to have you here, okay?
And actually, I don't know that I've ever told this story before on the podcast.
But essentially, the way that I got into live hacking events in the beginning was I was a plus one of a plus one.
So one of my buddies just kind of ran into Ted Kramer.
I don't know if you remember Ted Kramer.
Yeah.
And yeah, of course.
How could we forget?
And he was like, hey, man, you know, I'm a hacker as well.
And Ted was like, oh, you should come to the live hacking event in DC.
And so he's like, great.
Can I bring my friend Justin or RhinoRater, I think is what he said.
And then at that moment, John Botterini, right?
John Botterini was standing nearby and he's like, wait, did you just say RhinoRater?
Oh, he just found a really weird bug on like XYZ Target, right?
And then Ted was like, oh, cool.
Well, yeah, sure.
You know, let him come or whatever, right?
Yeah, if he can make it, bring it on.
And so I went to that live hacking event.
And I somehow placed eighth and became good friends with Kevin Rosenbaum, right?
At that event.
And because of that, they invited me to San Francisco.
And then when I get to San Francisco, I get a show and tell, right?
And after that show and tell, I was like, you know, they invited me to the next one.
So I was like, okay, the show and tell is the key, you know, to getting access to other
live hacking events.
And who is the master of the show and tell but Inti?
And every live hacking event that I went to, you know, at the time, you were in the live
hacking event circuit at the time as well.
Inti was getting show and tell after show and tell after show and tell after show and
tell.
It was sort of like a meme, you know, how is Inti going to get show and tell this time?
So that's why I'm really excited to have you on the pod because you just have these crazy
show and tell bugs.
And I think it's left a big impact on all of us that were in the live hacking event
scene at that time.
So with that, man, welcome to the pod.
Thank you.
And I got to say on the show and tell that the pressure really helped actually.
Yeah.
It was a paradox.
Like at first I didn't like it because I knew you have to perform for live hacking events,
but I also had to hit that holy grail of show and tell every single time.
Yeah.
But in the end, you know, I always found a way to do it.
So, and yeah, I'm still proud of that.
Yeah.
Most people have awards for like a lot of critical bugs, et cetera.
And most of my bonuses that I ever got was just like show and tell bonuses.
Yeah.
They won't be like the most creative.
Oh yeah.
Award.
Also known as the Inti award.
That's great, man.
Yeah.
It should get a trademark.
Yeah, seriously.
And, and, um, no, so, I mean, and I, and I think show and tell has a really unique part
of, it's a unique part of the live hacking event experiences because it is what helps.
I mean, obviously, you know, when you're at the live hack events, you're collaborating
with other hackers, you're talking with other hackers as well.
Right.
But the show and tell piece, you know, um, that is what really, you know, you get an in-depth
explanation with visuals with, uh, in your case, very engaging humor and, and, uh, very
creative attack vectors.
Um, and that's what helps us grow as hackers in that sort of context as well.
And I know some of the, the, the times that I've grown the most from live hacking events,
uh, is looking at show and tell specifically yours.
Um, so.
You know, the best moment in a show and tell, it's like when you're at like slide two or
three and everybody sees like a page that everybody, literally everybody.
And you just know, oh, damn, I just realized what I missed there.
And everybody is like super excited.
Yeah.
I was a little bit bummed out because they could have found that bug.
Dude.
I think you did that.
You used to do that so well too, you know, with the show and tells because it's like,
and then there's the moment you go to that slide and everyone's like, ah, you know, like
no, like, and you can almost hear the vision.
I mean, you really, sometimes you can, you're like, what's like this place.
So yeah, I think, I think that's such a great piece.
I can't even tell you how many times I've seen a bug in a show and tell that I've tried
like almost either that exact same thing on a different target or I've tried, like I was
trying similar things and I just gave up and I was like, ah, okay, I can't get around this.
And I just moved on.
So it's, oh man, it's amazing.
I think the big thing about your show and tell skills is just like, you have this amazing
presentation ability where like the showmanship.
Yeah.
Like it's, it's the showmanship.
It's like, you have a very good, like speaking, um, like experience.
I don't know.
Your, your public speaking skills are very good.
And so your way of presenting your bugs is very, like everybody can understand it.
Everybody's very involved.
Like you really hook the whole audience, myself included.
And so I think that that's just what, one of those things that makes the inty show and
tell just like so much more elevated.
Legendary man.
And, and so, well, thank you.
And it's, it's a nice compliment coming from, from both of you.
Um, and I think that honestly it's.
In a show and tell it's more about the story than the bug because in all honesty, not all
of my books were great.
In fact, I think I have the still whole, I'm holding the record of having the lowest ratings
of the rated book with the highest bonus on hacker one.
So I'm quite proud of that.
So I think that attack scenario involves like kidnapping the, the, like something like that.
It was, it was ridiculous.
And I remember, I remember that managers.
Like telling me like, I can't believe we're paying for this, but still they did.
It's about the story.
Dude.
Oh my gosh.
I just got flooded with memories that I remember that show and tell there was like some, some
like, like the character limit was too long for you to show the destination of where they
were going.
So you could kidnap the queen.
Oh man.
Oh gosh.
Um, yeah.
Just think about the impact.
Yeah.
I mean, yeah, that would be a disaster.
Um, all the real Royalists would be super.
That would be terrible.
It is really interesting that you point that out though, because I think like, there's always
like two aspects to like a bug bounty report.
And a lot of people, when they write a bug bounty report, they think about it like as if
it's, they're doing a show and tell, like, like they'll write it out and they'll be like,
well, I was looking through your website one day and I came across this really interesting
endpoint.
And like from a report perspective, most of the time they don't really care about that.
But if you were to take that exact report and like put it into a show and tell context,
it would probably do like pretty well because it's very like a storytelling.
Like it explains where you were coming from as a hacker, like the whole like mind, like
mental aspect, like how you're approaching the problem.
Those things really matter for a show and tell.
They don't matter so much for a report, but I think like everybody kind of has that ability
and it's about sort of like harnessing it to like show it in the right way.
Yeah.
But still during a live hacking event, I would argue that you have to, I mean, that team
and you, you know, this best of all, Joe, like you're getting hundreds of report
in a few days.
And if you want to get that show and tell, you got to ask yourself the question, if you're
drafting a report, how can I make this report memorable?
Yeah.
Without, you know, exaggerating too much because then they will think I'm a spammer.
Like there's a thin line.
But I remember in that report, my title said like literally results in kidnapping.
Oh my gosh.
It wasn't all right.
And my report got triaged right away.
I don't think there's many people.
I mean, that's some serious impact.
Yeah.
I don't think there's many people who could say that they reported a bug on HackerOne or
any hacking platform that says results in kidnapping.
Results in kidnapping.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
We have, we have a section.
One last thing I need to say about that.
Yeah.
Go, go.
Impact.
And then I'll let you do your thing.
Recently, and this was at, at Integrity and I do have permission to talk about this.
Great.
But it was with a client of course.
Of course, I cannot tell you who is client.
And so basically what the hacker reported was simply like an authorization bug.
I mean, it was like a missing permission check.
And we got to the client because it was fairly critical.
And the client started panicking and they said the actual impact of this is that people could
die.
Oh no.
So, so that was their impact assessment.
And sometimes if you think about it, we, big bounty hunters, you know, we look at an
eye door and we will see, okay, I can change this bit of data.
But if that bit of data is, for example, and it was not in that case, but if that's, for
example, a blood type of a person in a production environment, then you have a serious problem.
And not all hackers think like that.
Yeah.
I would say that if you want to find good bugs, you have to think like a hacker.
Oh yeah.
Not as a Q and A test.
Yeah.
And I all respect for Q and A testers.
They can find good bugs.
Phenomenal.
They can probably get paid more if they think about the story.
Yeah.
No, absolutely.
That's, that's, uh, that's crazy.
And, and whenever you're dealing with those products that intersect with, with real life,
you know, like, you know, sometimes it's, it's information and we'll talk about information
a little bit more later and, and some of your work that you've done with privacy related
stuff and all of that is very important.
But, um, you know, when it comes down to stuff like, you know, like transportation, like medical
stuff, like, you know, all of these things that interact with, with our bodies, right.
Then, um, things become way more critical.
And it does start, it does start to make you realize that the work that we do here, especially
in those, uh, environments, uh, has a very large impact on people.
And I have no doubt that, uh, you know, bug bounty reports have saved lives.
It's super interesting to me when we think about like how internet is starting to affect
more and more things.
Like I know we've talked about like internet of things and how everything is more internet
connected.
I think especially nowadays it's getting more and more.
So where almost everything is on the internet, like heart pacemakers, cars, computers, phones,
cameras, door sensors, door lock, like everything it's all on the internet.
And so many of those things are vulnerable attack surfaces to the point where even certain programs
will pull things out of scope.
Like United is a great example where nothing on the in flight, like infotainment or any
of that stuff is in scope because they don't want people to like risk hacking stuff while
the plane is in the air because there's so much risk involved there.
Even if the systems are completely separated, they don't want to even take the chance of like
having somebody test on it and say it's super, super interesting to see how that's changing
over time and how even though it's dangerous, more and more stuff is going online that probably
shouldn't be online, but is online.
And now those impacts of like chance of death, like this is like a real, this is like a real
thing and it's not just like an edge case now.
Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
And Inti, you've worked a little bit with the United program, right?
Have you hacked on them?
I have, yeah, I have in the past.
I'm not sure if I can disclose a lot about that.
I think they're a great team.
They have their own way of assessing severity.
Yeah.
Which is a choice.
Did you say, he said, it's a choice.
It is a choice.
Yes.
Well said.
So one thing I do have to say there is that I always, I'm, you know, I, as a, working at
the book bounty platform, I work with a lot of clients that may have their reasons.
And Joel, I mean, you've also seen both sides, right?
Mm-hmm.
Sometimes we hackers, we easily assume, or we just take, you don't even want to know how
many reports, for example, we see like in this hack-a-wall report or this, the crowd,
this got assessed this way.
Mm-hmm.
And for some companies, things are just different.
And what I just think is really important.
And in United's case, they do point that out in the program description at the defense is,
you have to be transparent.
It's all about expectation.
And if you're upfront with the way you score vulnerabilities, even though I, as a hacker,
do not agree with that, then that's, I mean, not their problem necessarily.
I can just choose to move on and to do something else instead.
Or in the case that we saw recently with VISS being implemented in the Zoom bug bounty program,
you can also choose to game the system with that same set of standards, right?
So, you know, I think, you know, Zoom uses VISS.
A lot of other places use CVSS.
And then I believe United uses the OWASP model for...
Risk rating.
Yeah, OWASP risk rating model.
Yeah.
But each one of these models has their own, I guess, quirks, right?
Little weird things that you can do as an attacker.
And one of the things we saw at the Zoom event was one of the hackers, Tom Anthony,
found a great way to game the system for VISS, right?
And get bugs rated higher than you would normally expect them to be rated.
And that worked out well for him in the event.
And I think that's just a part of the system, right?
That's a part of the game for hackers and programs.
Yeah.
I think that's a twilight territory, honestly.
Because, I mean, sometimes, and I mean, we do see both sides of the table.
Sometimes people will game the system to death.
And if you're a large enterprise, you can afford that.
And, you know, it's just a rounding error.
Especially for smaller companies.
Yeah, that hurts.
While they still care about, of course, being consistent, it can be a little bit tricky.
So, I do expect hackers to point out, I mean, I prefer hackers to point out any flaws that they may see in the policy.
Because we may even give an additional bonus for that.
It wouldn't be the first time that we said, okay, your report resulted in a policy change.
We're actually going to pay out for the policy change rather than for the bug that turned out to be.
So, I mean, even duplicates can sometimes be very exotic because, like, sometimes you will have, it's not necessarily the same root cause.
It's not necessarily the same code patch.
But then if you would look to the process, for example, on how they deploy all the instances, they could also have fixed it over there.
So, if a program wakes up with 100 submissions of essentially the same finding, well, are they really expected to pay out 120?
I wouldn't say it would be correct to pay out one.
I wouldn't say that it would be correct to pay out 120.
Sometimes you've got these edge cases.
And, heck, Luke, just to give him a shout out, has done a very interesting proposal on how programs or platforms should deal with these situations.
Oh, really? I don't know that I've seen that.
You haven't either.
Yeah, he's created big bounty standards.
Oh, yeah, I did actually see that.
I wouldn't. Yeah.
Huh.
Yeah, it's super interesting.
I think it's exactly what you're talking about.
Like, you see this a lot, both from, like, the program side.
I'm sure every hacker has kind of dealt with this situation in one form or another.
But, essentially, you're put in a situation where you may have found something systemic or you may have found, like, a repeated issue or something like that.
And you realize that this is something the team cares about and something that they'll pay for.
But it may be very, very similar.
And then you're in this ethical dilemma where it's like, should I make as much money as I can here and report these things as separate issues?
Or should I group them together in good faith and tell the team and hope that they award me accordingly for that?
And they'll probably fix it in one place and I'll lose a bunch of money.
But it's the right thing to do.
And I think that there's no real clean cut answer.
But I'll have to take a look at what Hacklick put together there because that sounds really interesting.
I do agree that, like, I don't think it should be really one or the other.
It should be kind of in between.
But it's really hard to define where that is.
And ideally, there's also, like, consistency across all platforms.
And that is also why, at least for the first time with Integrity, that we have had a meeting in Las Vegas during that call with both DuckRot, Hacklick, and Integrity.
Yeah.
To discuss some of the, I would say, issues, but maybe more challenges that we can work on together just so that the community and the client base and just the industry as a whole would benefit from.
And I think we need to align on like proposals for standards like that, but also other things.
For example, we had the unfortunate event that two live hacking events were colliding.
So they were basically during the same day.
Yeah.
But, you know, a lot of the top talent is present on all the platforms.
And then, you know, nobody really wins because as a platform, you see that your talent may want to go to the other or vice versa.
And then the hackers are also missing out on that additional event.
So I think it's just good for us to align a little bit more and just work together when it comes to the community.
And it's been really great.
I mean, there's such cooperative, wonderful people to work together with.
That's awesome.
And I was, the heart was warmed when I saw that post on Twitter, you know, with you and when Kodingo and Jessica and it's just like, you know, mom and dad and dad all living together in harmony.
And it's great.
And so, I mean, we did a little swagging.
Oh, that's cute.
I like that.
That's great.
Yeah.
And so, I mean, did that go, I guess, that was one of the things I had on the list to talk about.
Did that go like, I mean, do you think you'll see that collaboration?
Was that bridge sort of formed?
How did that meeting go from your perspective?
So, actually, there was already some sort of collaboration.
I mean, we think emailing, we've been slacking a lot.
Yeah.
Just, I mean, because if there's, for example, a new trend or a concern with the community or in the industry, I mean, it's always best for us to align.
Just, I mean, nobody, literally nobody wins from having disagreements on a community level.
It's also extremely confusing for the community.
Ideally, everybody has the same experience regardless of the platform and honestly also regardless of the program.
Right.
So, I think it's, I mean, we've been doing that in a more informal way and it was just good to now have discussions in person as well and also go for a more formal approach.
Meaning that if I suddenly drop that tomorrow, that this thing can be continued as well.
Right.
I'm not planning to do that.
Yeah.
We were talking about death earlier.
Kidnapped because of a bug.
This does remind me.
As long as the hackers are doing our jobs, keep Inti live.
This does remind me a lot, though, of like the Safe Harbor discussions that were happening like a couple years ago before Safe Harbor was sort of like a default type of thing across a lot of programs and platforms.
Where everybody was kind of aligned in terms of like how we felt like things should be going and how things should be handled.
But it was very much so up to programs and platforms individually to determine and set out the guidelines and the guardrails for how things would actually happen.
It'd be like this program specifically designates Safe Harbor in there.
And if they don't, then it's not there.
Right.
And like I think now that it's it's been sort of like adopted as Safe Harbor.
It's not like a hacker one thing.
It's not like a bug crowd thing.
It's not an integrity thing.
It's just like Safe Harbor is Safe Harbor.
And generally, most programs should have it and should try and adhere to it because that's what makes security research a safe and productive thing.
And I think we're starting to get there with the same type of like relationship where the programs like it really makes me think back on like the old rivalries between like Google and Apple and Adobe and how like Apple would never add Flash Player into Safari or on iOS and stuff like that.
Or how like iMessage is with like Android and that kind of stuff where we're now getting to a point where regulators are stepping in and saying this like type of business like disagreement or like business competitiveness isn't productive for the rest of the people who are within the ecosystem.
And it's time to step past that and put it to the side and just like move on and let your business be competitive in other ways and let there be certain ground based factors that are shared across all of the companies and across the entire community that everybody can take advantage of.
Yeah.
And honestly, I mean, I've I've been doing this.
I've joined Integrity in 2017 and maybe I've just been looking, but I've rarely come across any form of toxic competition.
That's great.
I've brought an echo on.
Of course, I mean, sometimes it may happen that, you know, a sales person may say something that is not fully aligned and then it's also better coach them, etc.
But I've always felt like in the eyes of the community, I mean, we share the same super valuable community and that at the end of the day, all platforms right now are still 100% dependent on the willingness of that community.
So it's, it's community that is boss and it's up to us to figure out how we can make sure that we make progress while maintaining the, we see our community as a client.
And then of course we also have the client.
Right.
And sometimes it's hard to balance that out.
I mean, I also sometimes read blog articles from well-meaning and well-intending hackers saying big bounty should be like this or like this.
And, and the thing is like, hypothetically, I agree with them.
They're making good points.
But then if you're walking in a platform environment where, you know, you have the industry, you have the clients and you need to make sure that everybody moves at the same pace, not only the hackers, but also the clients.
And I think that change can only accelerate if we as of the three biggest platforms can just work together.
So, yeah, I'm super stoked about this and I hope to be able to update you on more progress.
That's awesome, man.
Yeah, it seems like we're moving in the right direction with that.
And I think that'll improve the experience for everyone involved.
So I guess we went down a little rabbit trail.
I'm going to bring it back because one of the things we were talking about in the beginning was your ability to present and your ability to do show and tell and your public speaking prowess.
And I think that's a pretty core piece of the way that you've, you know, been in the community as a hacker.
And I imagine all of that actually started from your radio experience.
And as a podcast, you know, we're sort of like, I guess, radio adjacent.
So I want to get some, I want to hear about your radio history and how you kind of got into that field and any, you know, any tips and tricks you might have picked up along the way.
I mean, just to get that out of the way, I didn't have my own show or anything.
I was not a radio presenter.
I worked at the radio station, however.
Okay.
Gotcha.
And sometimes I was called in to tell a little bit about, like about cybersecurity in general.
If there was something going on, like WannaCrypt or whatever, I would typically go and talk about it for a national audience.
And basically then the challenge was to make sure that you explain things in a way that is factually correct while still making sure that people don't just switch stations.
Right.
Because you're getting too technical.
And that is, I've learned a lot in that space.
And it's a real art, honestly, because then you also, like, if you're not technical enough, then your core fan base or the people that really appreciate you as a hacker will start thinking, like, what is this guy saying?
Like, can't he just give some proper details?
And I always love that balance.
I think radio for me, because most of the times I was mostly doing the socials, just doing website stuff as well.
But I was in an environment surrounded by passionate people that knew everything about the subject that I didn't know anything about, which was music.
Right.
They were extremely passionate and, like, they were the best of Belgium.
And what I really like about Belgium as well is that, I mean, the best of Belgium, you can, there's only 11 million people here, right?
I'm not sure how many people live in New York, but maybe it's about me.
Yeah, it's probably less than that.
It's like four times out in California.
Yeah.
So, yeah.
But it also, I mean, I'm grateful for it because we all still have stuff like the public broadcast company and the national stations.
And it makes it, I guess, a little bit easier for a person like me to step up and to reach audience.
And I would come into the studio and we would talk with the prime minister of Belgium with politicians that actually can make change happen.
And one of those changes that I'm particularly proud about, and this is not only my work, I played a very tiny role in that, but is that unauthorized testing in some conditions is now completely legal in Belgium.
So, you can go ahead and hack a Belgian company.
So, you can go ahead and hack a Belgian company as long as afterwards you make your report.
And that can be on their computer.
There's a couple of rules attached to it.
But if there's like a SaaS business in Belgium, then you can just, if their computers are in Belgium and you're a Belgian citizen, you will no longer be prosecuted for hacking them and reporting a vulnerability to them.
Wow.
Which I think is super cool.
Yeah, that's awesome.
And it almost feels like, you know, like the parallel that you hear all the time with like enterprise organizations and then startups.
Right.
Like, you know, in Belgium, or I was actually just speaking to someone the other day from South Sudan and they're like, yeah, I was like talking to the minister of bloody blood.
And I'm like, oh, really?
Oh, that's cool.
You know, because it gives, you know, in these smaller countries, you can get access to, you know, these people a little bit easier.
And you can actually influence change, which is really cool.
During our last life hacking event in Belgium, we almost, but then a crisis happened, so it didn't go through, but we almost got like the prime minister of Belgium to just visit.
No way.
Wow.
Dude.
Yeah.
He really wanted to see the life hacking event, but something came in between.
Ah.
But that was really cool.
That would have been pretty sick.
I think I was also talking to somebody who, I want to say it was Saudi Arabia, that was at a life hacking event there.
And then like one of the princes or something came by the event and I was like, whoa, no way.
That's kind of nuts.
Yeah, because it...
I just hope they didn't have WhatsApp on the website.
Yeah, I know, right?
And it's a little bit weird, right?
It's a little bit weird, right?
Because it's like sometimes in security, we feel so niched down, right?
Like we're, you know, even within our community, you know, there are celebrities within our community and stuff like that.
But at the end of the day, we're a very, very small community.
And so whenever, you know, there's interactions with stuff like that, like people that are well known by the normal populace, right?
Like the prime minister, you know, whoever.
I think that's really cool to see that intersection.
Yeah.
Okay.
So that's the radio, you know, backstory a little bit.
So you came on, you were talking about cybersecurity in front of a national audience.
That's great.
Now, I want to hear a little bit of the hacker backstory.
So how did you get into hacking and how did you land in bug bounty?
Good question.
I guess, and I think this goes for most of us.
I'm a cheater, but not in relationships.
That is the disclaimer that I always have to say.
Nice.
I was never really good at video games or any games in general.
I was just lacking.
And then I guess I have kind of time on my hands to try to find a way to win.
And it started off with video games.
Do you remember like Pokemon where, you know, everybody was like trading?
Oh, yeah.
And there was like this missing no bug, like this mystery.
Yeah.
To me, that was just magic that you could catch a Pokemon that was more than a Pokédex by doing what?
By first going to talk to an old dude in Viridian Town and then flying over to the other side of the map to swim.
I mean, it didn't make any sense.
And I really wanted to know.
And by the way, LiveOverflow did an excellent video on that, which we were making in the sky.
Wow.
We don't even have to do anything.
It's so nice.
We'll just let him lead all of it.
This guy's a pro.
All right.
I really wanted to know how that stuff worked.
And yeah, like it just started from there.
And then I also figured like, I think everybody comes at the point where they have to decide.
Do I want to risk it?
Do I want to become a criminal or not?
But I was well raised by my...
I love hacking.
I always wanted to break in, but I didn't want to break into jail.
So, yeah.
Then I found Yahoo.
Yahoo was my first program.
And I got to see...
They had a terrible submission form.
It was like, do you know these mail to links that would open your profile?
Yeah.
So, you would fill in this form and then you would press submit.
And I had like mail two links, of course, like any sensible person.
I had it disabled in my browser.
So, I would fill in the form, click the button, nothing happened.
So, I was just assuming that it was getting sent.
But no.
It was supposed to open your email client.
So, you had to send them.
No.
So, yeah.
I was pretty disappointed.
I was quite happy with the launch of HackerOne that basically my reports would arrive.
And that's how I started with silly cross-site scripting bugs.
Then I, you know, I also did a lot of unauthorized testing because I didn't know better.
Yeah.
Of course.
I got lucky with that though.
So, I think one of the best stories there.
And by the way, kids don't try this anymore because I guess it's new management.
And I don't really, I've been telling the story a lot of times and I don't think they will allow me in their concerts anymore.
But I was a big fan of Metallica.
Oh, no.
So, the rock and roll or the heavy metal band, let's say.
And I knew that they had to deal with hackers like a few years back when somebody, I think, stole their whole album or something.
And they had like these meet and greets.
And I really wanted to meet them.
And it was like an online lottery system.
Basically, I found a way to do some cheating on the website.
But at the end of the day, because the ethical hacker in me stood up, I was like, I cannot take this spot.
I need to email that webmaster and tell them what I've done.
Tell them, of course, that, you know, this is not in bad faith.
Please just fix it.
And they said, hey, you know what, Inti?
You can still come to their show in Belgium.
You can come and meet Metallica.
They signed my keyboard.
I have a team with me.
This is for the YouTube watch.
No way.
This is like Metallica 2014.
That's crazy.
This is like, yeah.
Dude.
They all loved it.
That's awesome.
I got on stage with them.
And I could do like the backing vocals of their song.
What?
They're sleeping deaf.
And I was just supposed to say, deaf, deaf, deaf.
And I think they turned the microphone all the way down.
But still, I was standing there in front of that audience with Metallica just realizing, wow, this is the best idol that I've ever met.
So, yeah.
And that's basically, I mean, that was pretty cool swag.
And they're just, you know.
Dude.
Then I was working in a grocery store.
I quit my job the same day.
I was like, I'm going to do this with my life.
And I guess it's sometimes timing and being a little bit lucky and just keep on.
I think your first bug is the hardest bug.
And I just, you know, once I got there, everything followed.
Yeah, for sure.
I definitely, that's a common thing that I've seen with new hackers.
And I mean, old hackers too.
But like finding that first bug, some of it is timing.
And some of it is just like, there is like a natural, like, you know, acumen or whatever towards hacking.
Where some people just, it clicks like really quickly.
And they're able to just be like, oh, like that's all I have to, that's what's considered hacking.
I can definitely do that.
And then they just like, go do it.
Right.
And for other people, it takes a little bit and they like find that first bug and then it clicks.
And then they understand that that's what hacking is.
But I think whatever it is, like, there's always that like light switch moment where you finally sort of like, you understand like, oh, that's hacking.
Like, it's just like, I always like to say that hacking is not a skill.
It's a mindset.
And it's a way that you have to think about stuff.
Like, you just have to take ordinary situations and you have to kind of like flip it on its head and say, oh, okay, like if I approach this from a different angle and I use this system in a different way, I could, you know, abuse this in some unintentional manner.
And I could make it do things that it never was intended to do or never expected that it would be doing.
And that's, that's what hacking is.
It's, it's not like, you know, all this, like, oh, I'm going to put a balaclava on and sit in the dark.
Like, no, it's like, you know, you're just like putting somebody else's ID and where it should be or something like that.
Yeah, exactly.
And so many people also think that it's, that you need this huge amount of technical skill set.
There's a problem of some people, lots of people that I talk to, especially I see this with CPF players a lot.
Like, oh, I'm not good enough yet.
I need to learn more.
But then I will ask them, like, when do you think you've learned enough?
Because some of these bugs are embarrassingly easy.
But, you know, you just need some persistency.
I remember this, this story from, I mean, I was just sitting downstairs.
And all of a sudden, my wife came down.
And she said, I found it, I found it, I found it.
I was like, honey, I mean, she works in HR and communications, by the way.
I was like, what did you find?
And she popped the cross-site scripting while she was doing online shopping.
I was like, how did you?
She was like, I saw you doing that.
Remember a couple of months ago when you, I finally asked, what is that mysterious cross-site scripting thing?
And I showed her that she, she remembered it and she was like, just entering it in every single search box, every single website that she would come across.
And then months later, yeah, she found it.
And she, she then expected the bounty, but I had to tell her like, no, honey, all the bounty sites.
Yeah.
The harsh reality.
And stop doing this, by the way, because this will get you in trouble.
Yeah, exactly.
Wow.
That's, that's super hilarious though.
And it is like you guys are saying that, that sort of, you know, flash moment and you see it.
Sometimes it comes a little bit sooner and sometimes it comes a little bit later.
And I was talking to a friend the other day, we actually ended up, we actually ended up recording it.
So I think we'll probably put out some shorts or something like that a little bit later, but it was just a really good authentic conversation with somebody who's newer to hacking, but has a high propensity, has that, that clearly has that mentality, right?
For hacking.
And he's already found a bunch of bugs, you know, in a, in a hardware device, actually, just from playing around with it and bypassing stuff.
Awesome.
And, and, and, and, and, you know, we were just kind of talking about that.
And I think it, that is a blessing and a curse, that propensity, that, that, you know, ability to do it right off the way, right in the beginning.
Because, you know, when you, when you have a natural knack for it and you, you know, you find some bugs right away, you have to grind a little bit less.
And then when you go up against a target that doesn't match with your style, it becomes, it becomes very disappointing and very challenging and really destructive to your ability.
You know, your self-perception as a hacker, right?
And so, yeah, it's a double-edged sword, I always say to people that are kind of coming in and it's great if you've got it and it, but if you don't, you're going to learn how to, you're going to learn what hacking really looks like most of the time, which is sitting there, reading the JavaScript files, playing with the endpoints, opening 500 repeater tabs until your eyes bleed.
And then finally, you know, breaking in.
There's always a better hacker.
Yeah.
And, you know, you may be super happy with the book that you found or, or you may not find a week, a book for a week or something.
But I, I especially got this during life hacking events when you see, maybe you had a bad day or maybe the target was just not for you.
And you see all these people making so much money on exactly the same things that you've been looking at.
And then, you know, I just remember, I, I tried to then look at previous scoreboards and see, oh yeah, but in last events, they were way behind me.
So no, it, it, it just all evens out.
Nobody can be good at anything.
My personal technique was totally different than, than other people's technique.
And sometimes that technique pays off.
What I would do is I would really try to first set myself on objective.
What, what do I want to achieve?
I'm the hacker.
I'm the attacker.
And like, what kind of data do I want?
And then I would look for the most exotic ways to get there.
Like not the standard ways where I just like, I wouldn't even test like the, the search bar for cross-site scripting, let's say doing a life hack even, because it's, even if it only takes 15 seconds, it's going to be a waste of time.
Just making an invoice for that $3 split that you would be getting.
Yeah, exactly.
So.
Yeah.
That's a, that's a very important part.
And of, I think, and something we've talked about as well, Joel, in the past, these, this sort of goal setting piece.
Yeah.
And, and I think it's core to a lot of hackers mentalities.
And I think it really allows you to, I tested this in a, in a live hacking event recently, and I achieved both of the goals that I was going for.
And I think it allows you to, to really set up something that you want.
That's very critical.
Yeah.
I would also like flip them around.
So, so all letters would be at random positions that people would really recognize the passwords
anymore.
Right.
If you're filling in a caption, you don't expect it, but certainly you won't think, oh,
!
Maybe this is an anagram of my password.
So, yeah, it just, it just worked.
And I, I was able to during the show, I felt to present like this capture that would
actually just feature people's password and they would put it in and save it the plain
text Facebook.
Wow.
Whatever possible.
Oh my gosh, dude.
That's amazing.
Could you, can you imagine typing in a caption and be like, wait, this is, this is a perfect
anagram for my password.
You know, like that's hilarious.
That's hilarious.
And I think, you know, another way you could even, and I don't think this attack works anymore
because of the way same site cookies would work.
You wouldn't be able to iframe in a page and have the cookies still sent to it cross
origin, but unless they have same site set to none on those cookies.
But, you know, the other thing was like, everyone knows that time when they have to
submit a capture of like two or three times too.
So if it was longer, right?
Like you could, you could say, all right, the first eight characters are going in this
one and then they, you know, they submit it and it's going to be like, no, try again.
And then, and then try again.
And then, and then, you know, it's the next eight characters or whatever.
And like, you could, you could get up to like, you know, 16, you know, 20 something,
uh, you know, length of passwords.
I thought that was such a great deal.
Yeah.
And you, you, you presented this at a live hacking event and it looked exactly like captcha.
And I was like, I would absolutely do this, you know?
Like, and it's, that was terrifying to me.
I believe I called it the gotcha.
The gotcha.
That's it, dude.
Gotcha.
So freaking good.
Amazing.
Cool.
That's awesome, man.
I, yeah, we only had a couple, go ahead, Joel.
Well, I was just going to say like, before we run out of time, I did want you to talk
a little bit about the upcoming live hacking event for Integrity.
I know we're like kind of hard pivoting here, but again, we only have a couple minutes.
So would you mind giving us sort of a rundown of sort of what's going on and what's coming up
and all that kind of stuff?
Sure.
Yeah.
I'll just give it TLDR because I do have a hard stop.
But yeah, we're, we're running a pretty exciting life hacking event with Intel in October in
Lisbon.
Yeah.
It's going to be their, their first biggest life hacking event ever.
Well, we've done education life hack events or smaller scale, I've things with them before.
But this, this one is going to be insane.
The targets I can tell you are going to be very good.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
I've got to take care of our hackers as well.
I'm going to be very good.
Yeah.
And one of the things, and maybe there's the last thing I can say about that.
One of the things that I really appreciated about this, this kind of event is that basically
Intel is kind of democratizing life hacking events a little bit.
So they're like for local hackers and for people that happen to be around, et cetera,
they could just like apply for non-sponsored seats.
Yeah.
That there's always this, this mysterious group of people that always gets invited to life hacking
event.
And that's why we have rules for, but to some people it seems like it's, you know, we're
just inviting our friends and that's not really true.
There's a lot of parameters that come into play, but still people sometimes really want
to go.
And what I really love about this concept is that people can just pay for their flights
and go there and have fun and do it.
And I, yeah, I really think that is a cool concept that we are exploring for other events
as well, because I think that everybody at least should have the chance in their life
and that's one of these.
Yeah, dude, that's awesome.
I know so many people really appreciate that.
I've been talking to people and that has been making a ruckus in the community for sure.
You know, people are really excited about that.
Joel and I are both going to be there.
We're both very excited for it.
So yeah, really looking forward to it.
Inti, thanks for coming on, man.
We can find you.
Actually, you have two Twitters, so I don't know which one you want to call out.
Take Secure Inti.
Yeah.
So I have Inti DC, but that's my Dutch account.
That's your Dutch account.
Sometimes I tweet in English.
It's quite confusing.
So that started off as my radio account.
Okay.
That is also why I have a huge Dutch follower based on that.
Right.
I've made Sweden Dutch.
Everything big bounty related is going to be Secure Inti.
Secure Inti on Twitter.
Okay.
Awesome.
Anything else you want to shout out with your socials or IntiGridi or anything?
Shout out to you guys for setting this up and creating content for the rest of the community.
I think it's super valuable.
I love what you guys have been doing and I'm looking forward to see more of it in the future.
You guys are my viewers.
So thank you.
Awesome.
Thanks Inti.
Thank you very much.
That's awesome, man.
We'll definitely be looking forward to the live hacking event and seeing you on the IntiGridi
platform.
Yeah.
See you soon.
All right.
See you, man.
See you.
Bye.
That's the pod.